what is the role of death and fear of
death and life
well from our perspective the uniquely
human awareness of death and
our unwillingness to accept that fact
we would argue is the primary
motivational impetus for almost
everything that people do
whether they're aware of it or not so
that's kind of been your life work
your view of the human condition is that
death you've written the book warm at
the core that death is at the core of
our
consciousness of everything of how we
see the world of what drives us
maybe can you can you elaborate
like what how you see death fitting in
what does it mean to be
at the core of our being so i think
that's a
great question and you know to be
pedantic i usually start you know my
psychology classes
and i say to the students okay you know
let's define our terms and the ology
part
they get right away you know it's the
study of
and then we get to the psyche part
and understandably you know the students
are like oh that means mind
and i'm like well no that's a modern
interpretation but in ancient greek it
means soul
but not in the cartesian dualistic sense
that
most of us in the west think when that
word comes to mind
and so you hear the word soul and you're
like well all right that's the
non-physical
part of me that's potentially detachable
from my corporal container when i'm no
longer here
but aristotle's who
coined the word psyche i think um
he was uh not a dualist he was a monist
he thought that the soul
was inextricably connected to the body
and he defined soul as the essence of a
natural body
that is alive and then he goes on and he
says all right
let me give you an example if um
if an axe was
alive the soul of an axe would be to
chop
and if you can pluck your eyeball out of
your head
and it was still functioning
then the soul of the eyeball would be to
see
you know and then he's like all right
the soul of a grasshopper
is to hop the soul of a woodpecker is to
peck
which raises the question of course what
is the essence
of what it means to be human and
here of course there is no one
universally accepted conception of the
essence of our humanity
right aristotle uh you know gives us the
idea of humans as rational animals you
know we're
homo sapiens but
not the only game in town got joseph
hoisinger an anthropologist in the 20th
century he called us homo ludens
that were basically fundamentally
playful creatures
and i think it was hannah arendt uh homo
faber we're tool making creatures
uh another woman ellen dizzinayake wrote
a book called homo aestheticus
and following aristotle and his poetics
she's like well we're not only rational
animals
we're also aesthetic creatures that
appreciate
beauty there's another take on humans i
think they call us
homo naratans we're all we're
storytelling creatures
and i i think all of those uh
designations of what it means to be
human
are quite useful heuristically and
certainly worthy of our collective
cogitation
but what what garnered my attention
when i was a young punk was just a
single line
in an essay by a scottish guy who was
alexander smith
in in a book called dreamthwarp i think
it's written in the 1860s
he just says right in the middle of an
essay it is our knowledge
that we have to die that makes us human
and i remember reading that and i've in
my gut i was like oh
man i don't like that but i think you're
on to something
and then william james the the great
harvard philosopher and arguably the
first
academic psychologist he referred to
death as the worm at the core of the
human condition so that's where the worm
at the core idea comes in
and that's just an illusion to the story
of genesis
back in the proverbial old days in the
garden of eden
everything was going tremendously well
until the serpent tempts eve to
take a chop out of the apple of the tree
of knowledge and
adam partakes also and
this is according to the bible what
brings
death into the world and from our
vantage point
the story of genesis is a remarkable
allegorical
uh recount of the origin of
consciousness where we
get to the point where by virtue
of our vast intelligence we come to
realize
the inevitability of death and so
you know the apple is beautiful and it's
tasty
but when you get right into the middle
of it there's that ugly
reality which is our finitude and then
fast forward a bit and uh
i was a young professor at skidmore
college in
1980 um my phd is in experimental social
psychology and i i mainly did studies
with clinical psychologists evaluating
the efficacy of non-pharmacological
interventions to reduce stress
and that was good work and i found it
interesting but
in my first week as a professor at
skidmore i
i'm just walking up and down the shelves
of the library
um saw some books by a guy i had never
heard of ernest becker
a cultural anthropologist recently
deceased he died in 1974
after um weeks before
actually he was posthumously
uh awarded the pulitzer prize and
non-fiction for his book the denial of
death
uh um and that was his last book it's
actually his next to
last book i don't know how you pulled
this off but he had one more
after he died called escape from evil
and evidently it was supposed to
originally the denial of death was
supposed to be this giant
thousand page book that was both
and they split it up and the what became
escape from evil
uh his wife marie becker finished
i'll be that as it may in it is in the
denial of death
where becker just says it in the first
paragraph i i i believe uh that the
terror of death
and the way that human beings respond
to it or decline to respond to it
is primarily responsible for almost
everything we do whether we're
aware of it or not and mostly
we're not and so i read that first
paragraph lex and i was like wow okay
this dude you're on to something
you're on to something it's the same
thing it's the same thing
and then it reminded me i think
not to play psychologists but you know
let's face it
i believe there's a reason why we end up
drifting
where we ultimately come to so i'm in my
mid-20s
i got ernest becker's book in my hand
and the next thing i know i'm
remembering
uh when i'm eight years old the day that
my grandmother died
and you know the day before my mom
said oh say goodbye to grandma she's
not well and okay so i was like okay
grandma
and i knew she wasn't well but i didn't
really appreciate the magnitude
of her illness well she dies the next
day
and it's in the evening and i'm just
sitting there
looking at my stamp collection and i'm
like wow i'm gonna
miss my grandmother and then i'm like no
wait a minute
that means my mother's gonna die after
she gets old
and that's even worse after all who's
gonna make me dinner
and that bothered me for a while but
then i'm looking at the stamps all the
dead american presidents
and i'm like there's george washington
he's dead there's thomas jefferson
he's dead my mom's gonna be dead
oh i'm gonna get old
and be dead someday and at eight years
old that was my
first explicit existential crisis i
remember it being
you know one of these blood curdling
realizations
that i tried my best to ignore
for the most of the time i was
subsequently growing up
but fast forward back to skidmore
college mid-20s
you know reading becker's book in the
1980s
thinking to myself wow one of the
reasons why i'm finding this so
compelling is that it squares with my
own personal experience
and then to make a short story long and
i'll i'll shut up lex but
what what grabbed me about becker and
this is in part
because i read a lot of his other books
um
there's another book the birth and death
of meaning
uh which is framed um in from an
evolutionary perspective
and and then the denial of death is
really more
framed from an existential
vantage point and as a
young academic i was
really taken by what i found to be
a very potent
that you really don't see that often yet
usually evolutionary types
are eager to dismiss the psychodynamic
types
and vice versa and maybe only john bolby
uh you know there's there's other folks
but uh the attachment
theorist john bolby was really one of
the first serious academics to say
these um these ways of thinking about
things are quite compatible
and can you comment on what's what a
psychodynamics view of the world is
versus an evolutionary view of the world
just in case people are not oh yeah
absolutely that's that's a fine question
well for the
evolutionary types in general
are interested in
um how it is and why it is
that we have adapted
to our surroundings in the service of
persisting over time
and being represented in the gene pool
thereafter you used to be a fish
yeah we used to be a fish and also yeah
and i ended up
talking on a podcast yeah how we came to
be that way how we came to be that way
and so whereas the existential
psychodynamic types
i would say are more interested in
development across
a single lifespan and
but but al the evolutionary types
dismiss the psychodynamic types as
overly speculative and devoid
of empirical support for their views uh
they um you know they'll just say these
guys are talking [ __ ] if you'll pardon
the expression
and of course uh you can turn right
around and say the same about the
evolutionary types that they are often
and rightfully criticized evolutionary
psychologists
for what are called the just so stories
where it's like oh this is probably
why fill in the blank is potentially
adaptive and my thought
again early on was i didn't see
any um intrinsic
antithesis between these viewpoints i
just found them dialectically
compatible and very powerful when
combined
you